NEVER LISTEN TO.
>> ALL RIGHT, JOHN ROBERTS LIVE
AT THE WHITE HOUSE, THANK YOU.
FOR MORE ON WHAT THIS COULD MEAN
FOR THE PRESIDENT LEGALLY, WE
TURN TO THE JUDICIAL ANALYST
JUDGE NAPOLITANO, MAYBE WE PUT
YOU IN THE CATEGORY OF THOSE WHO
DO NOT TOTALLY BELIEVE THE STORY
ON THE PEN REGISTER.
>> I DO NOT BELIEVE THE STORY ON
THE PEN REGISTER, ON A DAY IN
WHICH THE PRESIDENT'S CHIEF
LAWYER THREW A BOMB SHELL INTO
MANY OF THE PRESIDENT'S
DEFENSES, DO YOU REALLY THINK
THAT THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT IS
GOING TO ADMIT THAT THEY LISTEN
TO PHONE CALLS FROM THE
PRESIDENT?
THEY MAY NOT HAVE RECORDED IT,
BUT I ASSURE YOU THAT THEY WERE
LISTENING.
IF THEY WERE LISTENING THEY
CANNOT USE ANYTHING THEY HEAR AS
A BASIS FOR AN AFFIDAVIT.
A PROBABLE CAUSE OR IN A
PROSECUTION.
THEY CAN SEND THEM SEEKING OTHER
MEANS TO ATTAIN EVIDENCE TO
SUPPORT THAT.
>> Shannon: PARALLEL
RECONSTRUCTION COMING UP ON
SOMETHING THEY WERE NOT SUPPOSED
TO HAVE ACCESS TO SO YOU FIND A
DIFFERENT WAY TO GET ACCESS TO
IT.
>> A DIFFERENT AND LAWFUL WAY SO
THAT YOU CAN PRESENTED TO A
COURT.
WHEN MICHAEL COHEN ASKS THE
DOCUMENT CEASED BY THE FBI BE
RETURNED, THE GOVERNMENT SAID
THERE IS NO PRIVILEGE HERE
BECAUSE OF THE CRIME FRAUD
EXCEPTION.
THAT MEANS THAT THEY HAD ENOUGH
INFORMATION FROM THOSE PHONE
CALLS TO SUGGEST THAT MICHAEL
COHEN OR HIS CLIENT WERE
PARTICIPATING IN A CRIME OR A
FRAUD AND MASKING THE PHONE
CALLS AS ATTORNEY-CLIENT
PRIVILEGE, AND THEY WEREN'T.
>> Shannon: LET'S TALK THROUGH
THE POTENTIAL LEGAL
RAMIFICATIONS OF WHAT RUDY
GIULIANI REVEALED LAST NIGHT.
HE SAYS HE DISCUSSED IT WITH THE
PRESIDENT.
HERE'S WHAT HE TWEETED OUT
TODAY.
WE WILL WALK THROUGH THIS,
"MR. COHEN, RETAINING A MONTHLY
RETAINER NOTHING TO DO WITH THE
CAMPAIGN FROM WHICH HE ENTERED
INTO THROUGH REIMBURSEMENT OF
PRIVATE CONTRACT BETWEEN TWO
PARTIES, KNOWN AS A
NONDISCLOSURE, THESE AGREEMENTS
ARE VERY COMMON AGAINST
CELEBRITIES AND PEOPLE AS WELL
IN THIS CASE IT IS IN FULL FORCE
AND EFFECT AND WILL BE USED IN
ARBITRATION FOR DAMAGES AGAINST
DISCOVERED.
THE AGREEMENT WAS TO STOP THE
FALSE COMMENTS MADE BY HER ABOUT
AN AFFAIR HAVING ALREADY SIGNED
A DETAILED LETTER ADMITTING
THERE WAS NO AFFAIR.
PRIOR TO THE VIOLATION BY
MISS CLIFFORD AND HER ATTORNEY
THIS WAS A PRIVATE AGREEMENT.
IF PLAYED NO ROLE IN THIS
TRANSACTION."
SO NOW WE GET TO THE QUESTION OF
HOW THIS MONEY WAS REPAID TO
MICHAEL COHEN, IS THERE
POTENTIAL FOR A FRAUD CHARGE?
>> THERE IS POTENTIAL HERE,
BECAUSE ONE OF THE REASONS THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS ABLE TO SAY
THAT HE KNEW NOTHING ABOUT THE
AGREEMENT IS HIS NAME DOES NOT
APPEAR IN THERE.
AND HE DID NOT SIGN IT.
MICHAEL COHEN AND MS. DANIELS
THEN EMPLOYER, NOT HER CURRENT
LAWYER USED A PSEUDONYM, DAVID
DENNISON IN PLACE OF
DONALD TRUMP, SO THE QUESTION IS
IT EVEN A
VALUED AGREEMENT, BECAUSE IT
BINDS THE PRESIDENT DID NOT
ACTUALLY SIGN IT.
THE PRESIDENT IS CORRECT WHEN HE
SAYS A NONDISCLOSURE AGREEMENT
IS COMMON, WITH RESPECT TO
CELEBRITIES.